[音楽]
皆さんこんにちは
40年前に私は中等部を卒業し
て
金額をこちら
この
全社会の扇動者からのことです福沢
諭吉先生が
慶應義塾の目標として
掲げたこと
がですこの全社会の洗脳者つまり
リーダー特に皆さんねこれからのリーダー
一番大事なのは
区力
だ
と今日はそのことをお話ししよう
と思いますここで言ってる聞く力とは
まず先に聞くではないのは何かという
ところからお話をし
ます例えば
誰かの話を聞くときにそっぽを向いてる
すごい
あるいは
途中で口を挟んでそうじゃないです
か
でさらには聞いて量で聞いてないっていう
のがあります
スマホもしまって
遮らずに聞いてるんだけども頭の中はもう
次に動いていっぱい全然お話が耳に入って
こない
聞くではない
ですじゃあ聞くとはどういうこと
それは
話してる人にすごい関心を寄せる
好奇心を持って対応するこれが実は効くっ
ていうこと
なんですこの関心の寄せ方好奇心の持ち方
も実は2種類あります
左側
withJUDGEMENT
これでいくと例えば話をしてる人が子供に
は小さい頃から英語学ばせるべきですよね
そうですか
口は挟まないんだけれども心の中で聞き手
は自分の考えに
照らしてそうだなとか違うなっていうこと
を考えるジャッジを挟んでいますそのこと
がちょっとした表情の動きとか
そうすると今度は右側にあるように
意外とジャッジの判断を
留保する一見判断を挟まずに
効くという聞き方があり
ます同じように話し手がやっぱり子供には
小さい頃から英語を学ばするべきですよね
もうちょっと聞かせてください
こういう風に相手の考えを受け取る声聞き
方です
この場合聞き手はもしかすると子供の英語
教育に関して全く違う考えかもしれないん
だけどもその判断を受け入れる
別の切り口で説明すると先ほどの関心が
関心をすることです
よ
痩せ方がミスジャッジメント判断をし
ながら聞く時っていうのは実はその関心を
話し手に向かっています
それに対して
こちらの聞き方は
話ししても話題話しての関心事に引き入れ
をするこういう機械なんですね
イメージとしてはその話し手の話題話し
てる関心事が
ディスプレイにあるいはホワイトボードに
書いてそれを話してる聞き手が並んで一緒
に流れ
こんな感じです
この時は土手のこう内面で起きてる共感の
度合いっても結構違ってまし
て左側の
ミスジャッジメント
自分と考えが近い人には強い業務を覚え
ますよね
だけどそうではないことを話し手が言っ
てる時っていうのは共感っていうのは
ものすごいできない下がりますそれに対し
てこの左の左側とジャッジメントの弾き方
ですと話し手の考えが自分と近くても遠く
ても
同じように
弱い
違いがあります
話し方ってTPOがあって皆さん
場面に使い分けたんですよねで同じ
コミュニケーションなので聞くということ
も実は話し手によって場によって
使い分けていくことが大切ですですので
ここで見せたことこの2つでどっちがいい
悪いということではありません
ただその上で
これからの社会の扇動者
リーダー
必要なのは特にこの右側の
何ででしょう
それはですね
多様性
イノベーション
変化対応こういったことを実際に
対面していった時にこのジャッジメントの
聞き方がこの3つの第一歩なの
ですまず多様性からいきましょうこの
ジャッジメント」って聞くということは
一人一人のその考えは関心を寄せるわけ
ですよ
ねポスト一人一人が違う
具体的に多様性ということが何なのかと
いうことが具体的に分かってくるわけです
それがあって初めて多様性っていうものを
活かすあるいは多様性を力に変えるそう
いう
リーダーの第一歩
で2つ目イノベーション
このリゾートジャッジメントで聞くという
ことは一見ちょっと判断を擁護するので
自分とは
異なる
考えというものにしっかり触れることに
なり
自分と違う考えられるのが橋をかけるこう
いうタイプなんですよね
自分と違う考えに触れた時に
文字が力強く論破したら気持ちがいいと
思いますよ気持ちがいいけど
新しい考えが本当に接点が持てないから
新しいもの出会いそしたらイノベーション
実はそうです
ねこれが
皆さんの思ってるアイディアと新しい考え
でイノベーションを離れる第一歩
で3つ目変化対応という
とジャッジメント
一旦ちょっと自分の考えを
擁護するこういう態度
言ってみれば知的
謙虚さの表れですよね自分には考えがこれ
すごくいいと思うやるべきだと思ってる
けれどももしかしたらちょっと違うかも
しれないもしかしたらもうちょっといい
考えがあるかもしれない
ということをちゃんと家に持ちながら
人と
これ
なんですよ
私たちが生きてる環境ってもう
テクノロジーの進展も早いですし社会の
状況も一人前には想像しなかったことが
起きるそんな枕のことだけじゃなくて実際
目の前のこの人が内心何を考えてるかって
実はわからなかったりするじゃない
ですから変化あるいは知らないほどそう
いう中で私たちは社会の成功者
リーダーに
なっていくそういった時にちょっと自分の
考えがあるんだけど違うのかもしれない
なっていうことを考えられる余地を
そういった意味でリサーチ
弾き方これができるようになることは
極めて重要だとではここまでこれからの
社会の扇動者にはこの多様性
イノベーションそして変化対応この3つが
大事でそれには全部この
男子大学
これをそうやって聞いてもらった
ものも話し手の方も実はそうやって歌う
ラジオと聞かれることでその方の中の
リーダーとしての素質が実は育まれていく
まず1つ目はそうやってその後
ジャッジメントでじっくり話を聞いて
もらうと自分に対する思い込みっていう
ものからちょっと自由になる
これは実は具体的にですね動機付け面談
モチベーションインタビューという
行動科学分野でも一番分厚い編成に支え
られた手法なんですねこれ何をやってる
かっていうの実は見たことジャッジメント
に聞いてもらうということを継続する
これにつけるんですこれが
依存症の
患者さんの支援から
企業の組織開発の非常に幅広く使われて
いる
と思うんですね
自分に対するかと思い込みっていうのが
少し解き放った時に
自分の深いところから
自分は何をしたいのかあるいは何が嫌なの
かこういうことはもう許せない
そんな自分のこう思い考えてもやもやと心
の中にあるかもしれないけどなかなかこう
言葉にはなかなか出ないあるいは自分でも
まだ本当に自分が何考えてるのかなんて
なかなかわから
くれる人がいるんで
初めて言葉になって出せるんですよね自分
でそういった言葉に出してみて
初めて
そういうことだったのか気がついたり見
ながらでもちょっとそういうことじゃない
んだよなそれを繰り返しながらちょっと
ずつ自分の思い気がつい深いところからの
志にまず自分が気がつく
で実際行動を起こすとかったら問題解決が
必ず
してるけどもこれも
じっくりまずその実際問題解決する行動を
起こす前にこうやってやろうと思うという
ことをジャッジメントで聞いてもらうと
そうでない場合に比べて問題解決力が
はるかに上がるということが心理学の研究
で分かってるんです
ねこのように自分に対する思い込みをから
ちょっと
解き放たれて自分の深いところから来る
志の気がつきで実際行動が起こすにあたっ
ては問題解決力を高めていく自分の中に
ある
潜在的な問題解決力を解放する
これを実際一人で全部やるのは
到底無理でやはり誰かにこうやって見せろ
とジャッジメントで聞いてもらうことが
この継続的にある
で人は
リーダーになっていく社会の扇になって
くる
このジャッジメント切って聞くってどう
やっ
てですね
実は作って
自分が聞いてもらったことがないと
聞くことはできないんですよ
ねおいしいラーメンを食べたことない人に
レシピ私作ってって言ってもまずできない
んだと思い
ますダメなことないからよくわかんないし
料理作ったからといってそれが正解の
それと同じように実は聞くということも
じっくり聞かれたことがないと聞かれた
ことがないどういうことかわからないん
ですが
思い出したら皆さんに必ずどこかでそうし
た経験はされてるはずです
ここにあるようにあなたが最後に誰かの話
じっくり耳を傾きいつだったでしょう
あれは誰かが本気であなたの話を聞いて
くれたのですか
これはこのリスニングの本の
冒頭にあった言葉
になるこれはちょっと思い出して
いただいその経験を思い出していただくと
ミニカーとジャッジメントで聞くという
ことを
ちょっとずつできるようになるんじゃない
か
と幸い聞く練習しようと思ったらもう日常
にいくらでも機会があります
からぜひ今日から
聞くということを始めてみてください
そして皆さんがこれからの全社会の戦国者
になっていかれることを願ってい
ますありがとうございました
[拍手]